the members of BTS are going to serve in
the military this is going to cost South
Korea billions of dollars billions with
a B South Korea has a law that says that
all able-bodied men must serve in the
military but Rich famous people have
always avoided this through a couple of
loopholes they renounced their
citizenship they've made up health
reasons oh and they also had this
entertainment Soldier program where you
could get out of serving in the military
by just making propaganda for the
military that program doesn't exist
anymore by the way back to BTS they've
said that all seven members are going to
serve their two years in the military so
we won't have like BTS K-pop for a few
years not a big deal right no it's a
huge deal this ban brings in around 3.6
billion dollars a year to South Korea's
economy that's the equivalent of like 26
mid-sized companies combined this one
band has led to billions of dollars in
the sales of cosmetic clothes food oh
and tourism seven percent of tourists
who go to South Korea say that they go
because of BTS the question is why
didn't South Korea's government step in
and help BTS get some exemption for
serving in the Army and should they have
done that